and joining me now from Oxford is senior
researcher at human rights organization
Article 19 Masa Ali madani Masa thanks a
lot for talking to us this afternoon so
these marches in London Berlin and
Washington but what is the situation
like in Iran itself are protests still
going on there
yes thanks for having me protests are on
going it's a bit unprecedented the
continuation we're seeing in in terms of
the continuation of protests in terms of
the brutality they're facing last
yesterday we saw these incredible scenes
from zohedan and sistan and baluchistan
a province you know known for an ethnic
minority the baluch the baluches that
are known for repression end of
September there was a massacre a really
in-depth report came out yesterday that
tried to document to the extent that it
could throughout the internet shutdowns
and limitations that 94 people died and
yesterday the city again came out in
protest saying from zahidan to Tehran we
will stand for Iran and so there were
protests all over Iran yesterday Tehran
mahabad zahidan so there's this
incredible
um you know perseverance and you know I
was looking at one particular civil
rights activist atina dayami
um she has been tweeting from on the
ground in Tehran and she just tweeted
you know we will not stand down people
are still protesting and the protests
are expected throughout today
um they're supposed to be strikes in
schools throughout Monday and Tuesday
and of course um you know the school
guilds are striking because of the
unprecedented attack on school children
um you know amnesty has documented over
23 children there's likely more that
have been killed by Security Forces
since the beginning of these protests so
the unprecedented brutality is not
um people are not stopping from
protesting and we're expecting more
internet disruptions already there's
difficulty reaching folks inside Iran
um but you know there are the pockets of
connectivity and we are seeing footage
come out and again yesterday in zahadan
there were some incredible footage over
54 people ended up being arrested
there's no research or reporting on the
death told of course that's very
difficult given so many different
limitations in terms of pressure on
victims and lack of access to the
internet of course traditional media is
not able to report on any of these
aspects so that is
restricting access to online platforms
like Twitter like Instagram like
telegram is that something the regime is
doing this time around
absolutely
um so I mean the last time we saw
something in terms of brutality and
protest was November 2019 and there was
about a week of a near total internet
shutdown we have not seen this kind of
near total internet shutdown we have
been seeing a very kind of surgical
shutdowns in certain areas lots of
shutdowns in system and baluchistan
where we've been seeing some of the
deepest repression obviously from the
very beginning of the protests they came
out and censored all available you know
foreign social media that had not been
censored yet like Instagram and WhatsApp
and they have been attacking virtual
private networks which are used to
circumvent
um the censorship and so finding vpns to
connect or being able to even find
connection because we're of course been
seeing mobile curfews since the
beginning of these protests where from
about 4 P.M to about 1 or 2 A.M
they shut down mobile internet
connection and of course the average
Iranian connects to the internet through
mobile data and smartphones so this is
extremely destabilizing for connecting
but of course we're seeing tons of
footage we're seeing you know the Masa
amini hashtag in Persian it's become a
historic hashtag with actual activity
from inside Iran so people are finding
connections although it is unstable
since masamini died a lot of
high-profile people around the world
have shown their support online a lot of
women cutting their hair but within Iran
are they able to and have they been
showing their support specifically high
profile people within the country
it's very difficult I mean we've had a
number of celebrities uh football
players who have taken stands some of
them you know had to flee and they've
had their properties confiscated
um and you know we've had El nazrakabi
who took a stand abroad during the rock
climbing competitions and so well she's
now under house arrest
um and you know I think the world saw
the images of people flocking to the
airport to welcome her after knowing you
know the pressure that the authorities
placed on her after her act of Civil
Disobedience so if people are taking
stands it's met with a lot of pressure
in various forms um and those rockabis
a family's home for example is now kind
of being held uh hostage
sorry where is Allah's
so elnaz is now under house arrest in
her family's home
um she's back in Iran
um she's you know in a smaller city
outside of the main city center she's
not in Tehran and she's under house
arrest at the as the latest news we got
in about her family's home which is
worth about 350
000 US dollars is now kind of under
hostage depending on what she does she
did post on Instagram very vaguely
thanking everyone for their support but
nothing further political okay Masa
thank you so much for talking to us this
afternoon